[Música]
la actualidad más destacada del
continente africano en france24
bienvenidos a áfrica de 7 días
comenzamos con los titulares el jefe de
la diplomacia rusa serguéi lávrov inició
una gira por áfrica el cairo fue la
primera parada del ministro ruso que
busca tranquilizar a sus socios del
continente sobre las futuras
exportaciones de cereales nuevos
enfrentamientos diplomáticos entre malí
y las naciones unidas- la junta
gobernante maliense expulsó del país al
portavoz de la misión de la onu la
minustah por sus declaraciones respecto
a la detención de 49 soldados marfileños
por parte de las autoridades de bamako
en seguida les ampliamos y al final de
esta edición les presentaremos el
proyecto colombia hecha opera la
propuesta de la fundación que tambo una
asociación que trabaja para el
acercamiento entre áfrica y colombia a
través del arte
después de egipto lávrov visitó a la
republica del congo uganda y etiopía
el objetivo es tranquilizar a sus socios
sobre las exportaciones de cereales
muchos países africanos dependen de los
granos rusos y ucranianos y están
preocupados por las consecuencias del
conflicto
áfrica importa alrededor del 40% de sus
reservas de cereales de rusia y ucrania
sérguei lávrov también abordó el tema
del acuerdo firmado entre moscú y kiev
para permitir la exportación de 20 a 25
millones de toneladas del grano
bloqueado en ucrania pero los últimos
ataques rusos con misiles al puerto de
odessa arrojaron dudas sobre la
posibilidad de que el grano salga de
ucrania sin embargo la afro mencionó que
los recientes ataques al puerto no
afectarán las exportaciones
y
[Música]
el episodio ha mencionado que tuvo lugar
en odessa no afecta en nada los
compromisos que rusia ha asumido incluso
en el marco de los acuerdos firmados en
estambul 22 de julio nada nos prohíbe
llevar a cabo una operación militar
especiales incluye infraestructuras
militares y otros objetivos militares
para
mejorar los objetivos de los ataques de
alta precisión se encontraban en una
parte separada del puerto de odessa en
la llamada parte militar y los objetivos
eran un buque de guerra ucraniano y un
depósito de municiones donde se habían
entregado recientemente misiles scuds es
muy prisión tuvo 72 horas para abandonar
mal y la junta militar que gobierna el
país expulsó al jefe de la minustah la
misión de estabilización de la onu en
mali oli 10 salgado este fue el último
episodio de la saga de tensiones
desatadas tras la detención de los 49
soldados marfileños en bamako el jefe de
la minustah comentó sobre los 300 los
recientes arrestos en una serie de
mensajes en twitter que las autoridades
malienses calificaron de provocación y
evocaron como motivo de la expulsión los
detalles en el siguiente informe
informaciones inaceptables sobre el caso
de los 49 soldados marfileños detenidos
en bamako esta es la razón que
presentaron los militares malienses en
el poder tras ordenar la expulsión de
olivier salgado portavoz de la misión de
paz de la onu la minustah según bamako
salgado declaró sin pruebas que las
autoridades malienses estaban informadas
de la llegada de 49 soldados marfileños
al país esta medida se produce tras una
serie de publicaciones tendenciosas e
inaceptables del interesado en la red
social 'twitter' en las que afirmaba sin
ninguna prueba que las autoridades
malienses habían sido informadas de la
llegada de los 49 soldados marfileños el
10 de julio las autoridades malienses
detuvieron a estos soldados acusándolos
de ser mercenarios que buscaban
desestabilizar el país
gracias al profesionalismo de las
fuerzas de defensa y de seguridad
malienses se comprobó que los 49
soldados marfileños se encontraban
ilegalmente en el territorio nacional de
mali en consecuencia fueron detenidos
inmediatamente a
costa de márfil pidió su liberación
afirmando que la presencia de estos
soldados en el marco de las operaciones
de apoyo logístico a la misma era
conocida por las autoridades malienses
tal y como afirmó olivier salgado en su
serie de tuits provocando la ira de
bamako según nuestras informaciones su
llegada del 10 de julio fue comunicada
previamente a las autoridades nacionales
estos últimos acontecimientos se
producen en un contexto de relaciones ya
tensas entre malí y sus socios
internacionales la crisis política se
une a una grave crisis de seguridad
desde el estallido de las insurgencias
independentistas y los ataques
yihadistas en el norte en 2012 mali es
un país sin salida al mar en el corazón
del sahel ha sufrido dos golpes
militares en agosto de 2020 y mayo de
2021 a principios de 2022 bamako expulsó
a las fuerzas francesas y el embajador
francés fue expulsado el 14 de julio la
junta militar anunció la suspensión de
las operaciones de la misma cambiamos de
tema un mes después de la masacre que
tuvo lugar en la frontera del enclave
español de melilla y la ciudad de nador
en marruecos la asociación de derechos
humanos amdh ha identificado 40 víctimas
mortales y más de 60 desaparecidos como
resultado del operativo policial
conjunto entre las autoridades de españa
y marruecos para impedir la entrada de
inmigrantes al territorio español los
hechos tuvieron lugar el 24 de junio y
suponen el episodio más mortífero
registrado a las puertas de ceuta y
melilla nuestra corresponsal en
marruecos sofía catalán nos cuenta los
detalles que se van conociendo sobre el
letal operativo
si a un mes desde que se produjo la
masacre de melilla nador se han podido
documentar al menos 40 víctimas mortales
y más de 60 desapariciones como
consecuencia del operativo policial que
llevaron a cabo las autoridades de
españa y marruecos eae según los datos
de la asociación marroquí de derechos
humanos y del colectivo caminando
fronteras a más del 30 por ciento de las
víctimas serían menores de edad y en su
día las autoridades de marruecos se
reconocieron 23 de estas víctimas son
mortales pero lo cierto es que hasta la
fecha no se ha hecho ninguna
investigación judicial ni tan sólo se
han identificado los cuerpos ni se han
hecho las autopsias según la versión
policial los migrantes murieron
asfixiados en una avalancha en el
perímetro fronterizo pero las imágenes
que se difundieron se podía apreciar que
las fuerzas aún marroquíes y las
españolas utilizaron una fuerza brutal
contra los migrantes y además todos los
testimonios de los supervivientes
coinciden aseguran que las personas
murieron asfixiadas a palizadas e
incluso tiroteadas y también como
consecuencia
las expulsiones que ejecutó la policía
española de la gente que logró acceder a
melilla y también como consecuencia de a
él los desplazamientos forzados que
ejecuta la policía de marruecos para que
los migrantes ya no estén cerca de la
frontera española ahora las comunidades
en movimiento y los colectivos de
defensa de derechos humanos denuncian
que las políticas migratorias europeas
son la causa de estas muertes y exigen
verdad justicia y reparación
es el último proyecto de la fundación y
tambo una asociación que trabaja para el
acercamiento entre áfrica y colombia a
través del arte esta nueva iniciativa
colectiva se lleva a cabo a través de la
música las fundadoras de quitan bocatín
dunga y malin palmas invitaron a la
reconocida cantante belgo congoleña
isabel cava to para montar en colombia
la ópera la flauta mágica' de mozart
tras varias audiciones realizadas en
todo el país 38 artistas fueron
seleccionados para representar esta
pieza que será estrenada en noviembre en
bogotá lionel busch y periodista
france24 asistió a las audiciones
montar una ópera en colombia bajo la
dirección de dos maestros indiscutibles
en sus campos isabel cava tu cantante de
ópera belga congoleña y stefano julian y
escenógrafo italiano esa es la nueva
iniciativa colectiva y artística de la
fundación quitando una asociación que ha
puesto en marcha numerosos proyectos
para celebrar el patrimonio común entre
áfrica y américa latina
[Música]
este nuevo proyecto es ante todo un
diálogo
es una filosofía de tambo todo este
proceso encaja con la filosofía de
quitar lo que es el énfasis en las
regiones la diversidad y la integración
del público y la conexión con artistas
de aquí de áfrica la conexión rica de
artistas y abertis actis en este caso
isabel cava tu que es congoleña y
stefano que es italiano es un melting
pot de culturas juntas ese es el
espíritu de tu tambo descripción esas
series y de campo la idea nació tras una
experiencia similar en kinshasa la
capital de la república democrática del
congo donde la flauta mágica' de mozart
fue puesta en escena en 2021 por isabel
y stefano repetirá este experimento en
colombia era algo para quitar en esta
filosofía de conectar artistas de allá y
de acá después de realizar proyectos con
artistas plásticos fotógrafos llegamos a
la música llegamos a stefanon giuliani y
ya isabel cava tour por un proyecto en
la composición que realizamos juntos en
el congo el año pasado y a raíz de eso
les invitamos a hacer algo parecido más
grande escala en colombia
juntando artistas de distintas partes
del país
isabel y stefano que respondieron a la
llamada de la fundación no jugaron ante
este ambicioso y exigente encuentro
artístico
[Música]
[Aplausos]
el punto si al apple
no estamos aquí para responder a la
llamada de un país que tiene talento una
diversidad cultural extraordinaria
físico newton dolly neri africain
lo que estamos tanto en la energía
africana como en el lado elegíaco de lo
andino también está todo el color y el
espíritu hispano en el sonido las
guitarras etcétera el idioma toda la
belleza de los dialectos la multitud de
esencialidad es todo eso nos trae aquí
para construir un proyecto completamente
loco con energía y sobre todo con
corazón y
esos tubos pero primero el casting
[Música]
desde la capital bogotá hasta la mítica
cartagena pasando por medellín y cali
cientos de artistas acudieron a las
audiciones viendo en ese proyecto una
oportunidad rara de formar parte de una
ópera
este proyecto representa cómo iniciar mi
vida como cantante y ese proyecto tiene
mucha ilusión para mí la verdad me hace
muy feliz ser parte de una vez
concluidas las audiciones 38 candidatos
fueron seleccionados para interpretar la
obra maestra de mozart la flauta mágica'
uno de los teatros más prestigiosos de
bogotá la representación de la obra está
prevista para noviembre
[Aplausos]
los departamentos y territorios
franceses de ultramar son un recuerdo
vivo del pasado colonial francés los
llamados tommy thompson áreas de la
republica francesas que se encuentran en
áfrica américa y oceanía hoy en
conociendo a áfrica hablaremos sobre
ellos los departamentos y territorios de
ultramar dependen como cualquier
departamento o región metropolitana de
parís del mismo modo de acuerdo con su
población tienen representación en la
asamblea nacional y en el senado las dos
cámaras del poder legislativo francés
antiguamente estas zonas eran colonias
que recibieron un nuevo estatus en
función de su nivel de autonomía se
dividen en departamento o colectividad
vamos a destacar los departamentos de
ultramar franceses en áfrica la isla de
la reunión de unos 850 mil habitantes se
encuentra en el sur del océano índico la
capital es la ciudad de sangin y tiene
la categoría de departamento y cuenta
con siete representantes en la asamblea
un poco más al norte en el canal de
mozambique está la isla de mayotté de
270 mil habitantes la capital es mamut
su también tiene la categoría de
departamento y en la asamblea en parís
cuenta con dos representantes
así despedimos la edición de esta semana
de áfrica siete días gracias al equipo
técnico a nuestro productor santiago
lópez y a ustedes por acompañarnos
[Música]